bei den nazis war das impfen freiwillig
in der ddr war es pflicht und in
westdeutschland zierten sich
eine deutsche impf geschichte
das robert koch institut in berlin
benannt ist es nach einem mann ohne
dessen entdeckungen es impfungen
vermutlich überhaupt nicht geben
tuberkulose in deutschland stirbt daran
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts jeder
siebte
1882 entdeckte robert koch den
tuberkulose-erreger der anfang vom ende
der seuche heute liegt robert koch in
seinem eigenen institut beerdigt ihn
besuchen darf man zurzeit nicht denn
draußen wütet corona robert koch ist
tatsächlich relativ schnell eine
nationale hoden gestalt das macht sich
schon vor den nazis bemerkbar in dem
wettbewerb zwischen pastor robert koch
da geht es letztlich dann nicht nur noch
um medizinische entdeckung sondern
natürlich um den nationalen wettbewerb
zwischen deutschland und frankreich jede
zeit hat ihre helden
1874 wird im deutschen kaiserreich eine
pflicht zur pockenimpfung erlassen die
erste impfung im zweiten lebensjahr die
zweite im 12
mit solchen schock fotos machen schon
damals impfgegner mobil von gift ist die
rede von selbstheilung und gesunder
lebensführung die impfgegner halten
kongresse ab organisieren sich in
vereinen kultur kampf der staat sagt ich
bin hier der souverän und ich bestimme
wie wir sozusagen die gute gesellschaft
gestalten und das heißt es wird damals
als selbstverständlich gesehen dass der
staatsbürger seine pflicht für den staat
leistet nämlich die impfpflicht und das
ist schon im 19 jahrhundert ein riesen
problem weil es viele gibt die dagegen
sind viele die gar nicht ging es impfen
sind sondern eben gegen die starts
albrecht ich kite wie es benannt wird
in den dreißiger jahren breitet sich in
nazi-deutschland die diphtherie aus zwar
gibt es eine schutzimpfung doch in der
ns-führung finden sich hart gesottene
impfgegnern impfen gilt ihnen als
jüdische erfindung die den deutschen
volkskörper vergifte
gerade bei den nazis gibt es eine sehr
starke impfgegner schafft da gibt es zum
beispiel julius streicher einer der
wortführer der den stürmer herausgibt
also das hetzblatt der nazis und der
stürmer ist voll von entsprechenden
meldungen über das impfen als
rassenschande als jüdische rassenschande
als versuch der juden den volkskörper zu
vergiften also das sind sozusagen so
bedeutung des impfens
verschwörungstheorien über die nazis
sehr gut verfangen und die auch dazu
führen dass man sozusagen bei der
liberalisierung des impfens im dritten
reich sehr viel weiter geht als in der
demokratischen republik eine impfpflicht
gegen diphtherie lehnen die
nationalsozialisten kategorisch ab
ausgerechnet die nazis setzen auf
freiwilligkeit
die frage ist so alt wie das impfen
selbst eben für ich für mich oder für
alle und geht es nur mich etwas an ob
ich mich impfen lasse
um eine solche auszurotten müssen alle
mitmachen
ich heiße nicole wenn ich erbost möchte
ich sei erzählt zu werden genauso wie im
zirkus
kinder wollen so viele es wären in
diesem alter
quält sie auch manchmal der gedanke
irgendetwas könnte dazwischen kommen
[Musik]
kinderlähmung ist grausam
schluckimpfung ist süß
der polier impfstoff wird er mit großem
druck entwickelt weil die polio ist eine
echte bedrohung weil man das nicht
vermeiden kann als kleinkind oder
jugendlicher polio zu kriegen polio
immer wieder breitet sich in den 1950 er
jahren die viruserkrankung solchen artig
aus sie trifft vor allem kinder es kommt
zu lähmungen der arme der beine und zum
ausfall der atemmuskulatur
in der brd setzt man auf eine
freiwillige impfung in der ddr auf die
impfpflicht in der ddr heißt des
sozialismus sei die beste prophylaxe
die ddr ist schneller machten 50 ist
polio impfung pflicht
oder bundesrepublik nicht dort gibt es
die prämien und im zentralkomitee müssen
sie mit einem fixen das angebot gemacht
haben der bundesrepublik sie anzubieten
dass man impfstoff liefert was natürlich
man abgelehnt hat weil es ist ja nicht
geprüft worden von ordentlichen
medizinischen institutionen
ein jahr nach der einführung der
impfpflicht ist polio in der ddr
praktisch ausgerottet in der brd bietet
die solche weiter im kalten krieg werden
im quoten zum propaganda instrument
das impfen ist ein stück weit dem
selbstverständnis sozusagen des
sozialistischen staates eingeschrieben
und ein versuch im wettbewerb der
systeme die nase vorn zu haben ddr
bürger hatten einen vollen impfkalender
bis sie 18 waren wurden sie bis zu 20
mal geimpft oft mit impfstoffen aus der
sowjetunion heute sitzt man auf
amerikanische oder deutsche stoffe denn
impfen ist immer noch und vor allem
eines ein politikum ich will das jetzt
nicht auf die heutige lage übertragen
und die vorbehalte gegen russische oder
chinesische impfstoffe jetzt nur auf die
politik zu schieben dann gibt es
sicherlich mehr gründe aber da sieht man
wie weit impfung und
infektionsschutz politisch aufgeladen
waren impfen als politische entscheidung
was wohl robert koch dazu gesagt hätte
klar ist nur dem virus ist es vermutlich
egal wo man politisch steht